hey 42 here cows ting is the official
sport of the u.s. state of Maryland
welcome to RIF 35 years after leaving
school the majority of people can still
identify 90% of their classmates studies
suggests that using sarcasm can
significantly improve your IQ 15% of the
air you breathe in a subway station is
human skin
Undertaker's have found that human
bodies do not decompose as quickly as
they used to they believe the reason is
because the modern diet contains so many
preservatives that they delay
decomposition after death Michael Jordan
earns more money from night every year
than all of the night factory workers in
Malaysia combined there are more
life-forms living on your skin than
there are people on the planet in the
1960s the CIA attempted to spy on
Russian embassies and the Kremlin by
turning cats into listening devices the
program called acoustic kitty involved
surgically implanting batteries
microphones and antenna inside cats and
ostriches I is bigger than its brain in
the 1800's eating lobster to prisoners
was considered a cruel and unusual
punishment like making people eat rats a
hummingbird weighs less than a penny
there are only two berry factories
remaining in France there's an 80%
chance that if you're 16 or older
you've already met the person you'll
marry if the Simpsons aged at a normal
rate Bart would now be older than Marge
was in the first series most antibiotics
are made from bacteria you're more
likely to become the President of the
United States than to win the lottery
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2